what the I'm Russian
this guy right here is American I'm
Russian I'm clearly the American pretty
cold here of course she has a Russian
jacket what kind of drinks are you
expecting I think of vodka with a w that
says vodka yeah okay let's surprise him
let's joking with Maserati offense looks
like beer yeah it's not like beer it's
just oh my god oh it [ __ ] so this
actually called your sh I love borscht
nope very different work is red beet
soup this is beer and vodka know what's
funny is that it tastes like beer box I
just need to move to Russia this is Miss
Martian that's how you know he's Russian
I need to take a nap
this is how the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles got their superpowers this is
Star Holden it's a traditional drink
from Georgia do I detect a hint of green
and bubbles I teach you Russian
tradition your idea yes before you drink
every time you must say toast to my
beautiful future Russian wife oh I like
that
I like it's not too sweet this is like a
Russian sprite that was great I mean I
keep them coming
keep it going let's go it smells like
nail polish remover they also on yeah
wait a minute mm-hmm my favorite
childhood ink is good yes this is great
doesn't taste like a nail salon
the acetone I know you said it's kind of
like a ginger ale with like a weird like
a slight hint of I don't know what that
is like ginger yeah this looks like some
sort of Russian Cola why does this smell
like a plate of dinner or something
your smile is why does it snow on an
afternoon
no that's horrible man in Texas we say
stuff like darling you're so pretty
you're the only Lone Star I mean I like
I love this that's a good one
do you think no you think black bread
rye bread and you soak it overnight and
water and that that creates fermentation
mm-hmm and then so basically this is
liquid bread this is a Ryoka which is
baked no it's very good no you're gonna
get used here maybe use yours this is
great we got to try water no smelling
anything
I don't understand this drink it doesn't
make any sense it tastes exactly what it
would taste like if you woke up in the
morning ya didn't brush your teeth still
end your nasty retainers in there and
then yeah it's like massive tater if you
took like beach water and then made it
like salsa it's like salsa beach water
it's mineral water it's very very
healthy it has a lot of amazing health
benefits and also it's the ration thick
to cure hangovers whoa it's not like
breast milk I don't want this why I love
it which is so weird oh my god an
aftertaste and burn my it vanished out
of my tongue have you ever have healed
from a force it's worse smell of course
it's or smell it's just worse well of
course no big deal
it's one smell it's all smell it's a
good news is that is no good it's very
high in whey protein no exotic horse
milk is what is it supposed to do for
you so if there's any benefits yeah what
[Music]
probably a healthy if all this stuff was
great I mean all that was great
besides the horse milk I mean it was
really delicious and I really enjoyed
all of it all right now we got to go get
some Russian drinks together go ahead
like a Russian happy hour like this
friendship can't stop here
put some pickles on the side my eyes are
open to Russian culture and my eyes are
definitely open to the beauty of a
Russian bride best dude on you Texas
ashes